[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public du débat des
reportages des experts en alcocktail que
l'on vous propose tous les soirs du
lundi au jeudi sur Public Sénat avec
deux actualités ce soir un ministre de
la Justice sur le banc des accusés Eric
Dupond-Moretti et renvoyé devant la Cour
de Justice de la République c'est une
première dans l'histoire de la 5e le
garde des sceaux se pourvoit en
cassation mais une question demeure
peut-il rester au gouvernement réponse
dans une minute jahir bolsonaro talon
Lula au premier tour des élections
présidentielles au Brésil le président
sortant fait mentir les sondages et
inverse d'une certaine façon la
dynamique de la campagne malgré un bilan
écologique économique et social des
astrueux le candidat d'extrême droite
peut-il l'emporter dans un mois ne ratez
pas l'analyse de nos experts dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord donc ce que
la Cour de Justice de la République
reproche à Éric Dupont-Moretti on le
détaille grâce à Guillaume Bertrand
pour un garde des sauts en exercice
c'est une première et rime
Dupont-Moretti est renvoyée devant la
Cour de Justice de la République cette
juridiction est chargée des délits
commis par des membres du gouvernement
pendant l'exercice de leur fonction
convoquez ce matin devant la commission
qui devait décider de la tenue d'un
procès le ministre était absent
représenté par ses avocats l'audience à
huis clos a duré une vingtaine de
minutes à la sortie ses conseils dénonce
une cabale politique il y a une
instrumentalisation de la Cour de
Justice de la République et du droit
pénal oui afin de afin de nuire à
l'action politique de l'actuelle mise de
la justice bien sûr c'était en 2020 tout
juste nommé ministre Eric Dupond-Moretti
ordonne des enquêtes administratives
contre plusieurs magistrats trois
d'entre eux avaient fait éplucher
quelques années plus tôt les factures
téléphoniques détaillées Derrick
Dupond-Moretti dans le cadre
d'investigation sur Nicolas Sarkozy une
autre enquête ordonnée par le garde des
sceaux concernant un juge qu'il avait
affronté dans une cour de justice
depuis ses accusations de prise
illégales d'intérêts suivent le ministre
et la question de sa démission est
régulièrement posée mardi dernier déjà
Eric Dupond-Moretti l'admé devant les
journalistes il s'attend à un renvoi
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République et à de nouvelles
interrogations je défendrai mes droits
comme tout juste ici et pour le reste
j'ai toujours dit que je tenais ma
légitimité du président de la République
de la première ministre et de personnes
d'autres et je veux encore ajouter pour
être tout à fait complet que cette mise
en examen ne m'a jamais jamais empêcher
de travailler les avocats du ministre de
la Justice ont déposés un pourvoi auprès
de la Cour de cassation sa décision est
attendue d'ici plusieurs mois
[Musique]
légitimité du président de la République
et de Elizabeth band je ne sais pas
s'ils sont ravis de cette patate chaude
qui leur est renvoyé mais du coup c'est
eux qui sont en première ligne comment
se fait-il qu'il maintienne ce ministre
et qu'il est nommé et qui aujourd'hui
qui le maintiennent me paraît impossible
enfin il est ministre de la Justice et
il va être jugé sur le comportement
qu'il a eu à l'égarder magistrat et que
la plainte de certains magistrats
mais la plainte elle a été déposée par
les deux syndicats de magistrats celui
de gauche et celui de droite et
l'association anticorps c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait vraiment il a contre lui la
profession des magistrats quand on est
ministre de la Justice et un petit
problème alors on va rappeler évidemment
la présomption d'innocence il est près
du 1900 et qui a eu un pouvoir devant la
Cour de cassation juste juste après très
rapidement annoncé par par ses avocats
émise appelle ski on l'a entendu dans
dans le reportage de Guillaume Bertrand
c'est extrait de la dernière déclaration
de du garde des sceaux qui dit je tiens
ma légitimité effectivement du prénom
République de la première ministre
qu'est-ce qui peut pousser Emmanuel
Macron je pense que ça tient beaucoup
entre ces mains à garder son ministre de
la Justice justement moi la réponse
justement à cette question c'est de me
dire il le savait quand il la renommé la
au mois de mai il le savait donc quelque
part pourquoi il ne tiendrait pas
finalement ce qu'il a dit sa parole
pourquoi il ne soutiendrait pas puisque
finalement il l'a nommé avec ce risque
là parce que le risque arrive et que
d'un coup ça arrive bon je pense qu'il
avait réfléchi à cette option là je
pense qu'il y a une espèce de
d'opposition de coup de force un petit
peu à donner avec le milieu pour essayer
de montrer ses muscles et de dire de
toute façon vous n'aurez pas à mon
ministre de la Justice et on va
continuer à réformer judiciaire ou le
milieu médiatique non non le milieu
judiciaire de le milieu professionnel
parce qu'ils sont en train d'essayer de
réformer ce qui est étonnant c'est quand
même temps le ministre
Éric Dupond-Moretti a obtenu des
rallonges de budget de pour son
ministère une première qui avait été je
crois acceptée mais c'était ça revenait
à Belloubet celle qui était
[Musique]
exemplaire je dis pas évidemment il y a
la preuve de présomption d'innocence
vous avez eu bien raison de le rappeler
mais c'est vrai que du point de cette
fameuse jurisprudence qui est qu'on ne
peut pas rester au gouvernement si on
est ou à la barre du tribunal ou mis en
examen ça pose une question alors c'est
vrai que c'est un ministre en même temps
emblématique il y a effectivement ce qui
vient d'être rappelé cette posture
d'Emmanuel Macron qui refuse agir sous
la pression une pression qui va de
l'extérieur il refuse mais c'est aussi
que c'est un ministre régalien d'abord
c'est un des principaux postes du
gouvernement ça a été présenté quand il
est arrivé comme une prise de guerre
incroyable une information qui semblait
absolument spectaculaire l'avocat le
plus connu de France le fameux
aquitateur arrivé au gouvernement donc
une prise de guerre importante et puis
surtout il y a aussi cette idée que
Dupont-Moretti défend depuis le début et
peut-être qu'il plaît Emmanuel Macron
qui est celui de casser un petit peu le
système du pont-moretti représente aussi
une justice qui se veut plus proche du
citoyen
plus simple plus facile moins cher plus
transparente et donc ça on sait que
c'est un fondamental pour Emmanuel
Macron qui depuis le début dit ce qui va
pas en France c'est qu'il y a des rampes
de situations c'est qu'il y a des il y a
des il y a des petites forteresses qui
se sont constituées donc peut-être c'est
que cette approche elle plaît sur le
fond Emmanuel Macron vous l'avez évoqué
l'une et l'autre cette
jurisprudence Balladur c'est le terme
qu'on employait un ministre mis en
examen doit démissionner regarder ce
qu'on dit l'association enfin la banque
je française de l'association
transparent si internationale se
maintient signifient la fin alors il
parle du maintien de d'Éric
Dupont-Moretti la fin d'une pratique
vertueuse selon laquelle tout le
ministre mis en examen doit démissionné
encore en vigueur sous gouvernement
Philippe cette pratique a été abandonnée
dans la seconde partie du mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron bon là il cite un
certain nombre de cas nous estimons que
la démission d'Éric Dupont-Moretti du
gouvernement permettrait d'éviter que
cette séquence ne nourrisse le sentiment
de défiance de l'opinion publique à
l'égard de l'ensemble de la classe
politique Catherine tricot 7 jurispr
date de l'époque Balladur mais rien dans
notre Constitution j'entendais ce matin
sur France Info une constitutionnaliste
disant il y a rien dans la Constitution
qui oblige un ministre de quel qu'il
soit à des missionné là encore on
pourrait rappeler le principe de la
présomption d'innocence
de 15 jours qu'on discute du fait que il
y a des responsables politiques qui sont
attaqués sur leur vie privée et qu'on
leur retire leur mandat politique et là
on aurait donc un ministre qui pourrait
utiliser les moyens du ministère pour
enquêter sur des magistrats qu'il y
aurait nuit par le passé et que lui
serait mise à l'écart il y a quelque
chose qui là n'est pas possible
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose qui dans la
société française demande de la
cohérence entre ce que l'on proclame et
ce que l'on fait et là je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron a trop dit qu'il
voulait une société une république
vertueuse exemplaire c'était ça le terme
pour ne pas l'appliquer et c'est vrai ce
que vous avez rappelé s'il y a trop de
cas maintenant alors qui qui se sont
répétés moi celui qui m'est venu en tête
quand j'ai entendu ça c'est l'affaire
Benalla c'est à dire que les autres
ministres comme Emmanuel Macron a
défendu c'était plutôt sur des
accusations de violences sexuelles que
il est monté en première ligne pour
défendre ses ministres que ce soit
Nicolas Hulot à Bad ou Darmanin mais
l'autre fois où il s'était écarté de la
règle à en matière de justice c'était
sur l'affaire Benalla qui viennent me
trouver et là on a l'impression en effet
comme vous dites c'est qu'il veut être
vertical et qu'il va couvrir ou qu'il
couvre je sais pas combien de temps ça
va durer parce que peut-être qu'il va
être obligé finalement de se ranger à
l'opinion publique qui va lui demander
monsieur c'est vrai que c'est en termes
de symbole c'est épouvantable
et ça va la situation va devenir
difficilement tenable pour pour
récupérer Dupont-Moretti on l'a dit le
Macron il a déteste des jugé il déteste
agir sous la contrainte donc ça fait
quand même deux cases qu'il faut cocher
et en plus il aurait l'impression de
donner raison
au milieu judiciaire vous renseigner au
sein des cadres magistrats qui avait
dénoncé la nomination d'Eric du
bourbonati avant même qu'on lui reproche
les turpitudes qu'on lui reproche
aujourd'hui donc c'est à dire que le
bras de fer était engagé des
salominations puisque sa nomination
avait été ressentie par une partie de
magistrats comme une déclaration de
guerre avait déclaré un syndicat et
c'est vrai que depuis
à l'époque Emmanuel Macron qui aime être
disruptif comme il le dit le mot est
égal Vaudé mais en gros nommé des gens
histoire de secouer le cocotier quelque
part et que la justice pour lui il
fallait le faire et que Nicole Belloubet
avait été assez calme et que là il
voulait mettre les moyens soit justice
c'est vrai que les moyens colossalement
augmenté il faut le rappeler depuis la
domination et des réguliers mais en gros
il y avait l'idée de réformer et vous
voulez pas de lui et ben je le laisse
quand même et puis vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir avec un avocat en
plus et donc un avocat chic et stylé qui
était le l'avocat et donc ça veut dire
vous l'avez tout à l'heure un bras de
fer parce que si on est dans un bras de
fer entre Emmanuel Macron et les juge ça
va pas s'arranger donc maintenant il y a
l'opinion publique
on va parler d'une autre information de
cette fin d'après-midi la mise en examen
d'Alexis colère le secrétaire général de
l'Élysée on en parle dans un instant
d'où il doit nommer c'est
ça le juger peut-être éventuellement
enfin là il y a un moment on arrive dans
une série télé c'est complètement
absurde là la situation elle va devenir
en effet difficilement tenable mais ça
veut pas dire que éventuellement il
lâchera moi j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
ça il y a ce bras de fer mais il y a
aussi ce côté opportuniste qui a
Emmanuel Macron et il fait avec les
moyens du bord et en effet il avait
rappelé Bruno c'était une grosse prise
c'était un coup médiatique d'avoir Eric
Dupont-Moretti en même temps il y avait
Roselyne Bachelot il y avait un peu des
grosses figures et probablement ça le
rassure parce qu'il y en a pas tant que
ça des grosses figures il y a Darmanin
il y a Bruno Le Maire il y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui sont montés comme
ça et qui pèsent un poids donc quelque
part c'est garder ses alliés il a perdu
quand même Castaner il a perdu Richard
Ferrand pour les législatives du coup il
faut quand même qu'ils gardent un peu
cette garde rapprochée qui peut l'aider
parce que je pense qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup autour de lui alors si Alexis
colère en plus à des problèmes donc il y
a cet aspect là mais évidemment que moi
je pense que pour les citoyens mais
c'est catastrophique et ça alimente les
tests de tous pourris ils sont qui
nourrissent on sait très bien qui se
Nour tendance à nourrit les populations
à droite est-ce qu'il a rééquilibré un
petit peu dans son dans la voie porte le
plus contre nationale et il devait faire
des terrasser le rassemblement national
on a quand même eu Marine Le Pen au
second tour Eric Dupond-Moretti s'est
présenté régional et c'est ce qu'on
appelle
la liste qu'il avait présenté au moment
de sa prise de fonction c'est très
impressionnant on avait le sentiment du
pont morétis ce jour-là nous dit que
d'une certaine manière il a presque
attendu toute sa vie d'obtenir ce poste
pour enfin pouvoir transformer la
justice et le catalogue qu'il prononce
ce jour-là est une liste extrêmement
impressionnante de réforme structurelles
de la justice sur lequel il y a assez
peu de dossiers qui ont pu avancé il
faut rappeler sur la l'histoire de la
jurisprudence Balladur attendez je vous
donne la parole là-dessus parce que va
nourrir votre votre démonstration j'en
suis sûr mais simplement pour faire un
petit retour en arrière de quelques
années campagnes présidentielle 2017 le
candidat Macron et l'invité de David
Pujadas on est en pleine affaire Fillon
David puis là je suis une demande s'il
renoncerait à sa candidature s'il était
mis à l'examen et vous allez lire ce que
le futur Président répond il répond oui
de la même façon que dans le principe un
ministre doit quitter le gouvernement
lorsqu'il est mis en examen donc ça
c'est la phrase du candidat Emmanuel
Macron en 2017 Bruno cotress on voit que
c'est ta géométrie variable j'ai pas
rappelé le homard de François de Gif
face aux autres affaires que vous avez
pu citer c'est quoi c'est le poids
politique de la personne mise en examen
qui compte le plus comment vous la
analyser c'est ce type de déclaration
qu'on est obligé de faire dans une
campagne électorale parce que finalement
s'il disait le contraire
et c'est vrai que du point de vue du
climat de l'opinion et c'est vraiment ça
le sujet cette jurisprudence Balladur
elle n'est au début milieu des années 90
dans un contexte bien particulier il y a
eu le départ obligé de Bernard Tapie du
gouvernement il y a eu de beaucoup de
scandales politiques du financement la
fameuse affaire Urba qui concerne à
l'époque le Parti socialiste donc il y a
eu tout un tas de noeuds et c'est dans
le milieu des années 90 début des années
90 qu'on voit nous dans nos enquêtes de
pignons décoller les indicateurs de
défiance des Français qui dit ce monde
qui est en train de bouger avec le
traité de Maastricht avec l'Europe avec
la globalisation et en plus on n'aurait
pas des politiques qui seraient vertueux
qui seraient exemplaires et donc on voit
à partir de ce moment-là une très forte
préoccupation dans dans l'opinion et de
ce point de là je pense que le juge de
paix sera quand même les mesures de
pions publics si le thermomètre de
l'opium public montre qu'il y a un
décrochage la popularité de l'exécutive
qui dit c'est pas normal vous ne jouez
pas votre votre rôle en maintenant un
ministre qui est mis en examen à ce
moment-là la messe sera dite mais de ce
point de vue là de ce point de vue là
c'est vrai qu'on est dans une situation
qui est une situation
qui du point de vue de la tension de
l'opinion publique rappelant un contexte
aujourd'hui économique très forte
inquiétude le les prix qui s'envolent
partout la facture d'électricité de ce
point là il y a pas tellement de place
pour effectivement un exécutif parasité
par une telle affaire juste le contraste
quand même on a ce ministre avec ses
affaires là et en demande aux Français
bientôt on va aller punir parce qu'ils
mettent au-delà de 19 degrés à la maison
donc il y a quelque chose qui relève de
l'absence
de contrôle
pas loin c'est vous culpabiliser en tout
cas et de l'autre côté on a ce ministre
là donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un moment
je pense que les Français vont en avoir
bonne vieille recette des années 70 on
fait la chasse au gaspi on a pas de
pétrole à des idées mais si c'est juste
des conseils de bon sens
je voudrais qu'on parle quand même dans
cette première partie il y a beaucoup de
thèmes ce soir donc on va essayer
d'aller vite d'Alexis colère donc le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée je vous
donne l'info mise en examen pour prise
illégal d'intérêt en raison de ces liens
avec l'armateur MSC fondé et dirigé par
des cousins de sa mère elle a aussi le
point de départ de la faire c'est une
plainte d'anticorps et Catherine tricot
c'est un peu la même on va pas tous se
répéter mais peut-être qu'il faut dire
le la proximité et le poids d'Alexis
colère dans l'appareil d'état depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron et président de la
République et oui c'est son bras droit
absolument passer son âme d'année quoi
non il est absolument là tout le temps
et il est au premier poste aux premières
loges pour toutes les décisions majeures
je pense là ça exprime aussi pardon de
le dire aussi qu'il y a il y a une un
mélange des affaires et de la politique
depuis Emmanuel Macron qui est un
président qui se veut pro business qui
est problématique c'est à dire que là en
l'occurrence il met au premier loge
quelqu'un qui est totalement impliqué
dans un acteur majeur de l'économie
française et donc bon bah c'est il le
sait aussi je veux dire que c'est pas
enfin c'est pareil c'est pas à l'insulte
donc ça voudrait dire quoi ça voudrait
dire qu'on se prive systématiquement des
personnalités de qualité qu'on a un lien
avec les milieux économiques et donc et
donc on aurait des gouvernements ou des
ou des équipes ministériales totalement
hors-sol enfin vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est pas non plus une c'est pas
non plus une la panacée
MSC je ne m'en occuperai pas et que dès
le départ il faut être capable de
circonscrire le périmètre de façon à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas ce mélange des gens
qui est là en l'occurrence et pas tant
c'est qui ne va pas il y a quelque chose
qui n'est quand même pas
clarifier dans les relations entre le
monde des affaires et
d'innocence la notion de conflit
intérêtsutif a du mal à avancer et c'est
là-dessus que si Eric Dupont-Moretti
c'était des parties ou écartés de toutes
les affaires qui avaient plus concerner
en tant qu'avocat le jour où il est
arrivé placement dôme on en serait pas
là d'une certaine façon donc c'est cette
notion-là qui qui a encore du mal
parfois à s'implanter dans le paysage
politique français dans les réflexes
alors la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique elle
fait quand même fait faire des progrès
là-dessus sur les déclarations
d'intérêts on en connaît beaucoup
beaucoup mais c'est vrai amour rapide il
y a eu d'importants progrès quand même
qui ont été faits en France sur cette
question il y a un certain nombre
d'années lorsqu'on regardait les
classements de qualité de la démocratie
en Europe on voyait que c'était un des
points faibles de la France c'était à la
lutte contre la corruption les conflits
d'intérêts et la France sur cette
dimension a repris du terrain à regagner
du terrain
par contre elle reste pas pour le moment
elle n'est pas en première division du
point du du classement international de
qualité de la démocratie mais on a quand
même fait des progrès là-dessus autorité
pour la transparente de la vie publique
différents codes d'éthique de
déontologie partout sur la question de
conflit d'intérêt deuxième thème de ce
débat 100% politique les difficultés de
Sandrine Rousseau de semaine après avoir
visé Julien Bayou sur le plateau de
l'émission C'est à vous la députée
Europe écologie des Verts et dans l'oeil
du cyclone hier elle participait à la
manifestation de soutien aux femmes
iraniennes elle a été accueillie comme
ceci
partout dans tous les pays du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu on va analyser ensemble les les
conséquences de cette séquence et puis
plus globalement de voilà de l'action
politique de son âme Rousseau depuis que
depuis quelques semaines la députée de
Paris fait beaucoup parler d'elle et pas
forcément en bien alors on sait que
c'est une habitué des phrases chocs du
buzz mais voilà l'écologie s'est attaqué
sa rentrée sur le barbecue et j'allais
dire elle finit sur le grill il y a eu
l'affaire Bayou bien sûr et là il y a ce
rassemblement de soutien aux femmes
iranienne où elle se fait siffler et
insulter par une partie de la foule on a
demandé de réagir ce matin elle était
invité de France Inter écoutez sa
réponse ce qui s'est passé hier c'est
que les trois femmes qui est de gauche
qui ont parlé c'est-à-dire Manon Aubry
mais aussi Laurence Rossignol et
moi-même avons été siffle et voilà je me
demande quels étaient les intentions de
ces de des manifestants de siffler ces
femmes
problème pour 100 euros c'est que
Laurence racingLe était visiblement elle
aussi à l'écoute de la matinale de
France Inter et classée matrice de
l'Oise est sorti de ses gonds en disant
c'est un mensonge faire croire que
toutes les femmes auraient été sifflées
c'est une manipulation que Sandrine
Rousseau assume ses positions il ne
cherche pas à nous embarquer toute sur
son bateau c'est un surjet l'ancienne
ministre réponse Sandrine Rousseau
qu'elle a effacer enfin le rétorquer
dans un premier temps vous l'avez été
moins et je vous l'accorde mais vous
l'avez été comme Olivier fort et on leur
lance Rossignol à répliquer non Sandrine
tu le sais bien bref on voit bien qu'ils
ne veulent pas évidemment se faire se
faire amalgamer par Sandrine rousse et
Laurence Rossignol qui a payé une vidéo
de son cours discours
que traduit cette passe d'armes mais que
son vrai nomsso est gêné très gêné même
et que quand la réalité ne lui plaît pas
ben elle la change parce que dans la
manifestation d'hier les voix qui l'ont
sifflé se sont pas prises au fait que
c'est une femme on vous rappeler que
c'était une manifestation pour soutenir
les Iraniennes qui arrachent leur voile
et que il y a des voix dans la
manifestation qui se souvenaient des
positions sur le voile de Sandrine
Rousseau il y en a qui porte des voiles
qui sont juste un embellissement
confiétel LCP il y a un an les femmes
qui sont voilées c'est pas l'islam
politique ce sont des femmes qui ont un
voile c'est tout ajouté-elle en décembre
sur une chaîne belge en fait Sandrine
Rousseau on est venu comme d'autres à
gauche à défendre le port du voile au
nom de la liberté des femmes à disposer
librement de leur corps et donc de leur
habillement parce qu'elle répète encore
aujourd'hui et au nom de la lutte contre
les discriminations que surbis certaines
femmes voilées au quotidien je disais
c'est pas la seule à gauche d'autres
l'ont fait par préoccupation aussi
antiraciste voilà mais aussi parfois
pour des préoccupations moins
induisentes c'est-à-dire électoraliste
et assumer faisant mine au fond
d'oublier un peu vite que le voile a un
aspect patriarcal
sexiste et que ce symbole religieux
voilà pour revêtir tout ça et puis la
gauche c'était pas la religion dans le
temps la religion c'était l'opium du
peuple ça a jamais été considéré comme
un facteur d'émancipation mais plutôt
comme un facteur d'aliénation mais le
problème c'est que la religion c'est
l'angle mort dans la pensée de Sandrine
Rousseau et de ses amis intersectionnels
qui dénonce à tour de bras l'obsession
l'oppression masculine l'oppression
capitaliste l'oppression blanche mélange
jamais ou très rarement l'oppression
religieuse et en particulier quand il
s'agit de l'islam donc prise dans cette
contre dans ces contradictions il ne
reste qu'à cette gauche là que le
mensonge ça c'est la version Sandrine
Rousseau ou que l'anathème version
Daniel au Bono qui a tweeté ce matin
bonjour à tous et toutes sauf aux gens
qui instrumentalisent la lutte des
femmes en Iran contre l'oppression pour
insulter et disqualifier la lutte des
femmes en France contre l'oppression
cela mangez vos morts voilà c'est écrit
la député insomnisent là on est un
sophisme doublé d'une insulte on touche
le fond merci Mathieu et mise à part ce
qui peut-être un mot de
communication politique puisque c'est
votre métier sur cette séquence les la
vidéo de Sandrine Rousseau qui est hier
à la République place de Républic à
Paris et puis ensuite cette prise de
parole ce matin sur France Inter ou
finalement elle met en cause Laurence
Rossignol pour se retrouver coincé elle
devrait pas peut-être souffrir en ce
moment une petite cure de silence
moi je pense que c'est une stratégie
très particulière c'est à dire que que
ça soit bien ou mal qu'on dise du bien
ou du mal elle est toujours dans le buzz
continuel il faut le dire que ça marche
ça fonctionne terriblement c'est une
très bonne cliente pour les médias dès
qu'elle barbecue hop on en parle pendant
une semaine à chaque fois qu'elle touche
quelque chose ou qu'elle parle de
quelque chose on est braqué sur elle et
on va en parler pendant une semaine donc
elle a une espèce de force moi ce que je
questionne plus derrière c'est en effet
la stratégie les mensonges au passage
tout ce qu'elle est prête à faire pour
ça et à quelle cause ça sert quelle
cause ça sert réellement c'est là où je
suis plus interrogative parce que on ne
voit pas quelque chose de l'ordre d'une
construction d'une ligne particulière
chez ELV évidemment son combat contre
les violences faites aux femmes ça oui
et le la lutte contre le patriarcat hors
religion comme vous l'avez rappelé mais
on ne voit pas véritablement de ligne
donc est-ce que c'est pour avoir le
premier rôle est-ce que c'est pour être
au devant de la scène et il est passé de
pas très loin
vis-à-vis de Yannick Jadot est-ce que
c'est pour développer quelque chose de
particulier on a du mal à le voir mais
il faut dire que c'est quelque chose qui
marche quand même terriblement comme on
le disait tout à l'heure elle était pas
connue Sandrine Rousseau c'est une femme
qui a débarqué et regardez comme elle
occupe les médias mais si elle ne porte
pas une cause ou une stratégie
particulière je ne comprends pas très
bien à quoi ça sert Catherine tricot
est-ce que derrière ça il faut le dire
il y a une stratégie de peut-être de
prise de pouvoir au sein du parti
europécologie et vert alors je pense
qu'avant la question d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts il y a la session du féminisme
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait derrière
Sandrine Rousseau revient dans la
politique à travers cette question
féministe c'est pour ça qu'elle dit
vouloir reprendre le combat si on était
écartés elle revient à la suite du
maintien de Darmanin au gouvernement
qu'elle a vécu comme une insulte un
affront quasiment personnel pour elle
qui avait été victime de de maltraitance
et de violences sexistes donc ce que je
crois c'est que Sandrine Rousseau inc
que ça nous plaise ou pas incarne une
nouvelle génération féministe dire qu'il
y a vraiment un nouvel âge du féminisme
depuis Mitou et c'est
physiquement c'est un autre âge une
autre génération les colleuses qui ont
qui ont collé dans les rues de nos
villes les noms des femmes qui ont été
victimes de féminicides ce que l'on
connaît
exactement au capital elles ont moins de
30 ans toutes ces femmes qui aujourd'hui
dénoncent le fait que moins de 1% des
viols sont condamnés en France elles ont
moins de 30 ans et
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que je crois que il y a dans
l'affrontement il y a des désaccords ce
que je saoule ce que ça nous enseigne
déjà premièrement c'est que les
féministes ce n'est pas un tout il n'y a
pas un seul féminisme il y en a
plusieurs il y a des différences et que
à l'intérieur de ce féminisme il y a par
exemple Elisabeth Badinter qui va
représenter un certain rapport au
féminisme à l'état à la justice qui
n'est pas celui de Sandrine Rousseau qui
est beaucoup plus
issu du mouvement féministe de base de
social je dirais qui travaille sur les
mentalités les représentations et c'est
en ce sens je crois que elle est c'est
une activité c'est une activité en
politique et peut-être que les choses
vont évoluer mais pour l'instant elle
est dans le coup de force pour
percer les médias déplacer les débats
faire émerger de nouvelles thématiques
etc on peut pas dire que ça leur est mal
réussi ça fait quand même la question me
too et là
dernière séquence avec la mise en cause
de Julien Bayou en direct
je dis pas que tout est réussi mais ce
qu'elle les thématiques qu'elle a voulu
mettre en avant qu'elle a voulu mettre
sur le devant de la scène et par exemple
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce qu'elle
a fait sur Julien Bayou mais ce qu'elle
a dit ce qu'elle a voulu mettre en avant
c'est le ce qui est une grande phrase
efféministe le privé est politique
c'est-à-dire que ce qui se passe dans
l'espace privé ne nous ne nous
désintéresse pas alors les féministes
l'ont beaucoup porté sur des tâches
ménagères la question de l'avortement et
la question de la sexualité
la police politique des meufs moi je
veux pas cette société là
d'accord avec vous donc c'est je vous
dis à débat à l'intérieur est-ce qu'on
n'est pas dans une dérive de ce nouveau
féminisme quand même alors que la cause
elle est enfin voilà on la porte juste
pour comprendre sur la table ce qui
n'avait pas ce que ce que les féministes
de la génération d'avant des années 70
n'avait pas réussi à faire mais je pense
qu'il y a eu aussi il y a des mouvements
dans le féminisme il y a de temps en
temps on oublie un petit peu et là je
pense qu'il y a un espèce de ras-le-bol
de vous parler des femmes de moins de 30
ans mais je crois pas que je crois que
ça rejoint d'autres femmes aussi qui
disent il y en a marre parce que on a un
cumul d'affaires là vous avez vu ces
dernières années quand même avec
toujours les mêmes questions est-ce
qu'on garde les mêmes alors qu'ils sont
accusés est-ce qu'on les garde pas
est-ce que si c'est le premier flic de
France ça craint ou pas qui soit accusé
de viol au bon non c'est pas très grave
il va c'est pas grave
la parole des femmes on sait plus quoi
en faire et je pense qu'il y a un espèce
de ras-le-bol peut-être comme il y a eu
dans les années 60-70 on va passer un
nouveau cap parce qu'on a encore des
droits on a encore de l'égalité à
obtenir et elle représente à l'incarne
en fait cette espèce de coup de force
moi je révolte pour obtenir c'est comme
s'il devait y avoir des des des c'est
comme s'il devait y avoir des dommages
collatéraux pour qu'on obtienne encore
parce qu'il y a encore beaucoup à
obtenir vis-à-vis des femmes et on s'en
rend compte avec ce type de parole un
petit peu extrême oui un peu radical tu
fais attention parce que dans un débat
on parle de sexisme si je j'interromps
en permanence
vous êtes d'accord aussi Bruno cotress
peut-être pour boucler cette séquence
sur l'existence de cette de ces cellules
on en a déjà un peu parlé sur ce plateau
mais ça m'intéresse d'avoir votre votre
regard ces cellules d'enquêtes sur les
violences sexistes et et sexuelle au
sein des partis politiques on voit bien
que effectivement il y a il y a il y
avait un vrai progrès à s'emparer de la
question et puis on voit que c'est c'est
pas si facile ça marche pas bien et
malgré tout la justice avec tous ses
défauts je suis d'accord avec vous il y
a trop peu d'affaires qui sont
instruites
le premier point quand même globalement
c'est plutôt une bonne chose que les
organisations politiques
progressent sur l'idée d'être moins
déboîte noire et d'avoir des instances
qui régulent les choses de ce point là
c'est toujours un progrès pour une
organisation d'avoir des instances
internes qui ce qui gèrent les conflits
il y a beaucoup de progrès qui restent à
faire sur toutes ces dimensions en
France pas seulement dans les
organisations politiques mais aussi
économiques donc globalement une bonne
chose qu'il y ait ces cellules
par contre c'est vrai que on est au
début de ça et là pour le moment c'est
vrai qu'on a pas trouvé le bon modèle
parce que ces cellules c'est d'abord
comment elles rendent des comptes ce qui
est fondamental pour une instance qui a
un certain pouvoir y compris un pouvoir
qui est pointé du doigt ou bien pouvoir
qui est de rendre public une information
donc comment elle rend compte de quelle
manière à qui comment elle comment elle
s'y prend par rapport à la justice
c'était elle ce que dans ces astuces il
y a l'idée que comme un peu la
l'histoire de l'article 40 pour les
fonctionnaires qui cisent voient un
comportement délecture ont une
obligation légale dans la vertu de
procureur de la République pour tout
fonctionnaire d'État donc voilà donc ça
peut toute cette question donc
globalement c'est plutôt une excellente
chose de voir les organisations
politiques progressées elles ont encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire sur la
transparence sur le fait de rendre des
comptes sur le fait d'améliorer leur
gouvernement évidemment après il y a
toute la problématique qui est comment
on cadre tout ça dans un état droit qui
doit être respectueux des
droits des droits de chacun droit
de sa défense droit de ne pas voir sa
vie privée jusque dans les détails
exposés même si effectivement je
trouvais très important ce qui a été
redit tout à l'heure qui est un point
fondamental non seulement de la
politique mais tout simplement du droit
l'espace privé n'est pas un espace où on
peut faire ce qu'on veut parce qu'on a
fermé la porte évidemment aujourd'hui je
suis chez moi je fais ce que je veux pas
du tout donc c'est important de le
rappeler et qui a pas une séparation si
stricte entre le privé et le public je
voulais juste rajouter un mot c'est
qu'en fait dans cette affaire là aussi
elle nous a amené à nous interroger et
elle déplace les normes c'est à dire
qu'il y a des choses qui étaient
acceptables qui aujourd'hui ne le sont
plus et ça c'est quand même un effet de
la politique c'est-à-dire que tout ne se
juge pas tout ne relève pas de la
justice au sens de la justice de l'État
de droit il y a aussi les partis
politiques les organisations les
mouvements féministes ont à faire
évoluer les consciences et d'une
certaine manière là on nous avons bougé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des choses qu'on
accepterait plus qu'il
conscience à la fin du mois le projet de
loi prévoit aussi et surtout peut-être
la modulation des indemnités en fonction
de la conjoncture économique quand ça va
bien on les durcit quand ça va mal on
les assouplit des mesures qui sont
rejetées en bloc par les syndicats alors
un autre grand texte une autre réforme
le projet de loi sur l'accélération du
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
il sera examiné avant l'hiver au Sénat
en première lecture il prévoit de
simplifier les procédures
administratives pour raccourcir les
délais de déploiement des projets
l'objectif c'est d'aller beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite sur les énergies
renouvelables alors que la France n'est
pas parvenue atteindre ses objectifs en
2020 autre texte important qui sera
débattu au Sénat à lobe me le projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur il sera examiné
par les sénateurs avant les députés ça
sera le 11 octobre ça mesure la plus
significative elle doublement de la
présence des forces de l'ordre sur le
terrain d'ici à 2030 alors tout ça c'est
le calendrier on va dire théorique de
l'examen de ces textes au Parlement ça
peut dérailler parce que le gros morceau
de la collection automne-hiver du
travail parlementaire c'est le budget
2023 son examen va débuter ce mois-ci et
ce sera un vrai test pour le
gouvernement est-ce que les républicains
voudront vraiment rendre la tâche facile
avec à l'exécutif parce qu'ils vont
jouer le blocage avec les oppositions
les discussions autour du budget pour en
tout cas s'étendre en longueur sauf si
le gouvernement décide de jouer la carte
du 49-3 une carte qu'il peut jouer à
l'Assemblée nationale mais pas au Sénat
et puis notez qu'il y aura aussi
plusieurs débats au Parlement sur la
guerre en Ukraine il y en a aujourd'hui
à l'Assemblée nationale il y en aura un
au Sénat ça sera le 26 octobre il
pourrait aussi avoir un débat sur
l'immigration d'ici à la fin de l'année
l'avantage Thomas de ces débats pour le
gouvernement c'est qu'il n'engage pas à
grand chose et qu'ils peuvent permettre
pourquoi pas de déstabiliser les
oppositions sur des sujets très clivant
comme la Russie ou encore la question
des frontières merci Steve Jourdain pour
toutes ces explications tiens justement
le le débat sur la guerre en Ukraine
Bruno cotress il est quand même si on
fait il est quand même piéger pour le
rassemblement national
[Musique]
on voit régulièrement ressortir ces
vidéos dans lesquelles Marine Le Pen ou
Jean-Luc Mélenchon soutenait la Russie
après l'invasion de la Crimée en 2014
alors 8 ans après elle sont toujours mal
mine de rien c'est ces vidéos est-ce que
vous l'analysez comme ça moi je crois
que en fait à gauche ça c'est plutôt
réaligné c'est à dire qu'il y aura des
questions à gauche qui vont faire débat
pendant le la séance la session
parlementaire mais je crois pas que ce
sera tellement là que ça va ça va cliver
je pense que tout le monde s'est remis à
peu près d'accord sur ce sujet là en
revanche que je trouve un tout petit peu
inquiétant c'est que Marine Le Pen en
fait elle est toute seule elle est en
majesté là dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire
les sanctions ne tapent pas la Russie et
mais elles nous font du mal à nous moi
je ressens là une faiblesse politique et
peut-être une force pour elle parce que
on ne répond pas à cette à cet objection
qu'elle apporte et qu'elle est seule à
porter et ça pour moi qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement il répond depuis c'est moi
quoi
pour pour
être prêt à payer le prix de notre
divers
c'est quelle est la seule à dire en fait
on est en train de faire des choses qui
nous vont nous peser qui pèse sur notre
notre je ne dis pas que je partage le
discours de Marine Le Pen voilà je ne
partage pas néanmoins je vois une
faiblesse parce qu'elle est elle peut en
tirer profit politique je pense que
quand même l'Italie on voit bien ce qui
s'est passé c'est-à-dire que quand il y
a un consensus général et qui a qu'une
seule voix sur des sujets comme ça qui
s'expriment il faut il faut s'inquiéter
c'est-à-dire que là en l'occurrence
Marine Le Pen on la laisse seule couvrir
ce champ là qui est un champ qui n'est
pas complètement balisé parce que ça des
Français assimilent les difficultés
souvent à tort parce que ce n'est pas
que l'Ukraine qui est responsable la
difficulté dans lequel on se trouve mais
qui est assimile cela à l'Ukraine et
elle est la seule à dire en fait on fait
des sanctions qui nous font à nous et
pas tellement à la Russie je pense qu'on
est je crois que ça lui donne un
positionnement de force et à mon avis le
positionnement que que le rassemblement
national va avoir à l'Assemblée
nationale va être différent du début
c'est à dire qu'on avait une opposition
assez constructive c'était on vote si
c'est intelligent si c'est bon sens on
va voter même si ça vient du
gouvernement alors que maintenant je
pense qu'ils vont avoir un
positionnement qui revient un peu à la
campagne de Marine Le Pen c'est à dire
défendre le pouvoir d'achat des Français
être du côté de ce que la gauche
pourrait incarner et qui n'arrive pas à
en plus la nups avec toutes les affaires
dont on a parlé c'est plus difficile je
pense qu'il y a un vrai risque en effet
parce que ce qu'on voit pas arriver
parce qu'on va arriver à dans l'hiver on
va arriver justement avec les vrais
problèmes énergétiques peut-être des
coupures des difficultés à payer pour
les particuliers
c'est les entreprises aussi parce que
pour l'instant merci dit 300 entreprises
juste qui sont en difficulté mais on
sent que ça commence à monter les
collectivités sont en train de réclamer
d'ailleurs la droite va monter là-dessus
dans le budget dans le projet de loi de
finance et collectivité elles peuvent
déjà pas payer leurs factures elles vont
demander des rallonges à l'état elles
vont pas pouvoir les entreprises comme
elles l'ont fait pendant la crise covid
alors vous dites Thomas oui et on aide
on a un fond Ukraine pour les
entreprises de l'ordre de 3 milliards
d'euros mais il est tellement compliqué
que les entreprises y arrivent pas on le
prolonge on essaie de développer quelque
chose de plus simple mais il va y avoir
tout un réseau économique toute des
filières qui vont souffrir énormément
des particuliers aussi et en effet je
pense que Marine Le Pen elle se met sur
ce filon qui au fur et à mesure va
trouver de l'écho dans la population et
dans le secteur économique et comme elle
infuse un petit peu dans cette France
périphérique que la gauche n'arrive pas
à apprendre elle va sûrement avoir se
positionnement là et je pense que ça va
être compliqué pour le gouvernement et
c'est important qu'on discute de ces de
ces questions là ça me fait penser à
l'Europe finalement c'est comme des
sujets qui étaient tabous avant parce
que si on parlait de ça on était taxés
d'être rassemblement national ou c'est
pareil pour la Russie c'est de se dire
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut discuter
des sanctions est-ce qu'on peut discuter
de ce qu'on fait ou alors est-ce qu'on
est tout de suite taclé d'être populiste
ou d'être rassemblement national c'est
c'est un tabou ça me permet de faire
parce qu'elle est de ce côté là mais
peut-être que il y aurait à discuter
parmi d'autres particuliers il y a
beaucoup de textes on l'a vu grâce à ce
Steve Jourdain important qui sont
attendus dans ces dans cette session
parlementaire Bruno cotress si vous
deviez la comparer à un jeu vous diriez
quoi vous savez quoi sorte de poker
menteurs et une partie de poker menteur
évidemment parce que les républicains je
voudrais gros au fond ils sont à la fois
ceux qui peuvent permettre à Emmanuel
Macron d'obtenir enfin cette majorité
absolue après laquelle il court en même
temps ils doivent cultiver leurs
différences ils ont eux-mêmes une
élection interne très très importante et
donc un peu un jeu de poker menteur on
joue aussi à se faire peur le chef
d'État brandi le 49-3 à la menace de
dissolution la menace de dissolution
paraît très peu probable dans une
situation de grande inquiétude de
l'opinion publique d'une popularité
l'exécutive qui tiède et d'un contexte
économique qui est assez problématique
et très sombre celui qui joue au jeu de
la dissolution ne s'est pas bien ce qui
peut lui revenir en échange donc voilà
on a cette dimension de poker menteur de
jeux stratégiques ou pour l'exécutif ici
il s'agit de mettre les autres pieds du
mur en disant chiche les républicains
chiches que vous pouvez aller jusqu'à me
défier à voter une motion de censure
avec la France insoumise vous pouvez
expliquer ça à vos électeurs à vos
sympathisants donc voilà il y a ces
dimensions et on voit qu'autour de tout
ça quelque chose d'important se dessine
pour les républicains et notamment dans
la perspective déjà de 2027 quelque part
Erine tricot ça veut dire que le parti
LR va être l'arbitre des réformes dans
les dans les prochaines semaines
tout à fait ce que vous venez de dire ce
que je pense c'est que c'est 2027 est-ce
que ils ont avoir une légitimité à
présenter un candidat face à ceux qui
vont vouloir reprendre le flambeau
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'est déjà que Darmanin et Philippe sont
sur les rangs pour 2027 mais on a du
côté des républicains Laurent Wauquiez
notamment qui a décidé d'être candidat
et que donc la légitimité de sa
candidature et son succès possible
dépend de la distance qu'il aura su
prendre avec la politique menée par
Emmanuel Macron donc aujourd'hui il va
leur falloir construire il va pas
simplement falloir l'affirmer il va
falloir construire et légitimer cet
écart avec la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron pour l'instant ils ont pas trouvé
ce qui Emmanuel Macron ne leur facilite
pas la vie leur donne beaucoup de ce
qu'ils demandent moi je me pose la
question parce que on a vu avec les
retraites qu'on était plus par exemple
sur la réforme des retraites on a
entendu Emmanuel Macron brandir
justement la dissolution donc on était
complètement sur la méthode en fait moi
ce que j'espère et c'était la demande
des Français d'avoir eu cette assemblée
un petit peu particulière qui aura des
débats parce que c'est ce qu'on a vu
depuis les premiers mois de l'Assemblée
nationale on a entendu parler de taxes
sur les super profits on a entendu
d'autres sondes cloche alors qu'avant
c'est vrai qu'on avait une assemblée qui
obéissait globalement est-ce que Jupiter
avait décidé et j'ai l'impression que là
on parle beaucoup de méthodes on parle
beaucoup de formes il va falloir voir si
en arrivant sur le budget on va pouvoir
continuer à parler du fond être dans les
idées parce que c'est ça que demande les
Français aussi c'est de discuter c'est
de faire des véritables choix en termes
de dépenses de l'État en termes de choix
même stratégique je sais pas d’énergie
nucléaire énergies renouvelable et pour
l'instant on a l'impression qu'on est un
petit peu obéaba de la forme des calculs
politiques et juste de la méthode merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois tiens on
en parlait tout à l'heure c'est toute
dernière minute concernant l'affaire MSC
Alexis colère le secrétaire général
de l'Elysée reste à son poste à l'Elysée
après sa mise en examen ce sont des
sources de l'entourage d'aller s'y
colère qui a donné ces informations à
nos collègues de l'Agence France Presse
merci encore à tous les trois